quite high-profile folks go yeah
everyone knows elon musk goes there
isn't it pretty open got a boat
you know
you know there's a it's called art cars
they all make art cars and like part of
the
part of the burn what's so beautiful
about it is like
you can't buy anything there man like
you you i've heard
i don't know if this has changed
it's been a bit because of the pandemic
but
the only thing you could buy was ice and
coffee
and i think maybe that's changed i heard
some whisper that that's changed but
so that means that
it's a gifting economy is what they call
it and so
people will just give you stuff talk
about having to struggle with deserving
stuff man what are you gonna [ __ ] do
when the camp next to you
is like every morning making the best
iced coffee that you've ever had in your
life and they just are giving it all
away till it's all gone what are you
gonna do it's
it's the best
ever and then you're giving things to
people and then you you learn stuff like
you learn these really interesting
lessons like uh
one of the times i went there
got all these uh
strawberries looks might not sound like
a big deal but
when you're out there in the dust and
you're not at one of like the like
hardcore like luxury camps which do
exist out there
you know you've got these like items
where in my mind i'm like yeah these are
gonna be just for me and my girlfriend
my special stash fruit and this or that
and then like
two days in
you're walking around your camp
with the strawberries that you were
coveting and everyone's so happy to get
like cold strawberries and you've
realized oh my god this feels so much
better than the way a strawberry tastes
so you learn something experientially
there uh which is an incredible thing
it's an incredible thing um man now i'm
wishing i'd decide to go to burning man
have you been a few times yeah
i just know like
uh at least people were saying it was
elon musk's boat like yeah like this i
think it was like a it's like this
massive it's art cars and it was this
party on this thing you could just
anyone
can go
on the boat like no one's like there's
no guest list
you just go on there i never saw him
there but that you know everyone's
whispering elon musk is here
you